bonsoir nous sommes le 6 mai merci de
nous rejoindre pour cette nouvelle
édition de votre journal de fin de
semaine sur tv fils au cours de la
prochaine demi heure nous reviendrons
sur les annonces du gouvernement en
faveur des professeurs des écoles
comment les enseignants perçoivent le
coup de pouce salarial prévu à un an de
la présidentielle 2017 sport également
avec du tir à l'arc et a aussi murray 11
ans licenciée aux archers de guyancourt
est actuellement l'un des plus grands
espoirs de la discipline en france vous
découvrirez son portrait et puis comme
chaque vendredi le zapping de
l'information locale depuis lundi avec
la campagne des candidats à la primaire
de la droite et du centre dont les
yvelines bruno le maire était à
versailles et le comité de soutien à
françois fillon dans le département
vient d'être lancée à noter aussi le
développement cette semaine des premiers
compteurs linky dans les yvelines la
direction maurepas pour débuter cette
première dans le département justement
la commune a mis en place un budget
participatif le concept des habitants
peuvent voter sur internet pour élire
les futurs grands projets de la commune
l'enveloppé conséquente 150000 euros
parmi les dix projets retenus on
retrouve par exemple la rénovation dans
skate park la création des espaces de
loisirs pour les enfants ou encore des
aménagements pour les routes on écoute
le maire de la commune grégory gary
astier c'est au micro de michael almy
d'euros je pense que c'est nécessaire
c'est associe des habitants les morgiens
à l'avenir de leur ville c'est une
démarche différente aussi de penser
l'argent public et puis bah ça permet
bien évidemment de d'associer tous les
habitants au travers d'une cause commune
qu'est l'intérêt général servir
l'intérêt général et date limite pour ce
vote le samedi 7 mai pour l'instant plus
de 250 personnes ont participé ne pas
perdre confiance en soi lorsqu'on l'on
recherche un emploi à maîtriser les clés
de l'entretien avec un recruteur voici
quelques-uns des objectifs du rendez
vous proposés à la ferme de bel ébat de
guyancourt ce matin le public est monté
sur la scène du théâtre le reportage de
fanny bourdon
bonjour reprendre confiance en soi grâce
au théâtre c'est tout l'enjeu de cet
atelier à la ferme de bel ébat depuis
quinze jours c'est une dizaine de
demandeurs d'emploi qui se retrouvent
tous les jours pour monter leur propre
pièce de théâtre c'est essayer de former
un groupe une cohésion de groupe et
c'est de leur donner confiance et
essayer de faire en sorte qu'ils osent
parce qu'ils arrivent tous en dix ans
mais je voudrais pas monter sur scène
donc on a quinze jours pour pour les
pour rendre les personnes plus confiante
et se dire que non ils vont nous ayons
fait hommes femmes jeunes ou âgées sur
scène on retrouve tous les profils loin
d'être inactif
on rencontre des apprentis comédiens
avec le désir de travailler rencontre
des gens qui qui sont actifs en tout cas
qu'ils veulent l'être qui veulent bouger
qui veulent travailler qui veulent
montrer ils arrivent à l'heure c'est
quand même un gros travail continue à
travailler chez eux
je suis capable moi qui étais moi qui ai
échappé très tôt à ma cité quand on est
sur une scène il faut pouvoir avoir de
s'exprimer fois assumé il faut il faut
être entendu il faut c'est quelque chose
que moi j'ai du mal à lever tous les
jours
donc c'est ça me permet de reprendre
confiance en moi et d'être beaucoup plus
communiquant avec les autres car tu sais
que tu ne veux plus de ta vie d'avant et
ça c'est sûr
c'est pas franchement évident mais mais
c'est plaisant et on va voir le résultat
après une semaine d'écriture et une
semaine de mise en scène
tous ces efforts seront récompensés la
troupe se produira devant un public
mardi soir pour la première partie d'une
pièce professionnel à moins de 20%
d'opinions favorables dans les sondages
françois hollande peut-il espérer un
deuxième mandat de la part des électeurs
en 2010 est le chef de l'état multiplie
en tout cas les gestes à destination
d'un électorat traditionnellement
tournée vers la gauche
ainsi cette semaine il vient d'annoncer
la revalorisation du salaire des
enseignants du premier degré pour la
rentrée qu'en pensent les principaux
concernés la réaction ce soir de
bertrand mesure secrétaire départemental
snuipp-fsu 78 syndicat des professeurs
des écoles bonsoir bertrand mesure que
pensez vous tout d'abord de cette
annonce des enseignants du premier degré
vont voir leurs primes annuelles porté
de 400 à 1200 euros
alors en fait c'est pas tout à fait une
prime parce que la prime supposerait que
on fonctionne comme dans le privé avec
des éléments qu'ils soient donnés en fin
d'année dont il s'agit tout simplement
de d'aligner l'indemnité de suivi des
élèves sur celle du second degré puisque
vous savez que depuis la réforme des
années 90 les enseignants du premier
degré sont considérés comme professeur
des écoles et leurs grilles indiciaires
et annie ligne et sur celle des
certifiés par contre l'indemnité
correspondant a suivi n'avait pas été
aligné que depuis maintenant trois
quatre ans c'est quelque chose qui est
en train de se mettre en place
c'est juste à dans l'ordre des choses
c'est une c'est ça une avance et c'est
tout simplement le rattrapage d'une
situation qui n'aurait pas dû exister
sur ces 20 dernières années que ce que
ça intervienne maintenant à un nom à peu
près de l'élection présidentielle ça
vous surprend vous vous dites que c'est
une démarche électorale or après le
calendrier de ce type d'annoncé est un
calendrier qui appartient au
aux politiques je sais que chaque année
il est de bon ton de faire plaisir à
telle ou telle catégorie d'électeurs
supposé pour donner ici ou là ou retirer
ici ou là quelque chose
bon voila nous tout simplement ce qu'on
constate c'est que si on prend la
situation des enseignants actuels c'est
un jeune enseignant qui débute donc un
master 2 gagne 1,17 fois le smic
c'est pas très élevé c'est même très
loin d'être ce que ça pouvait tourner
autour de 2000 euros brut par mois
enfin non pas du tout quel est le
salaire justement les balaurs le salaire
d'un jeune enseignant c'est aux
alentours de 1300 à 1400 euros en début
de carrière sur le net se rendait en mai
tout à fait rationnel
oui oui on travaille en être vous ne
pouvez pas aller voir votre banquier en
disant je gagne tant brut c'est ses
lunettes qui m'intéresse c'est toujours
important effectivement précisé
véritablement les salaires et c'est
peut-être l'occasion de le faire puisque
vous êtes présents aujourd'hui donc à l'
embauche un professeur est à 1300 euros
environ aides quelles sont les
perspectives d'évolution alors les
perspectives des vents le professeur des
écoles qui sont concernés par cette
oeuvre est un professeur des écoles qui
va thermique qui va aller en fin de
carrière et qui va arriver à l'accès à
leur classe qui aura son dernier échelon
or classe ce qui ne concerne qu'une très
faible minorité des professeurs des
écoles va terminer autour de 3000 euros
nets ce qui est bien en-deça de toutes
les données qui existent au niveau
européen puisque même dans des pays que
l'on dit confrontée à une grave crise
économique comme par exemple l'espagne
le salaire des enseignants du premier
degré est bien supérieur à celui des
français je ne parle même pas de
l'allemagne ni deux ni nos amis du
luxembourg qui profite à plein de de
toutes les dérives fiscal que leur état
a pu mettre en place donc les annonces
qui ont été faites sur les
revalorisations salariales ce n'est
finalement pas suffisant encore ce n'est
pas encore suffisant alors écoutez il ya
deux éléments déjà c'est pas une
revalorisation salariale
1 il s'agit d'abord d'une
d'un régime indemnitaire qui s'aligne
sur celui du second degré et puis
deuxièmement ce qui concerne
l'organisation syndicale vous a eu ses 1
2% versée en deux fois en sachant que
dans le même temps les cotisations
retraite des fonctionnaires augmente
donc on est bien loin d'une
revalorisation qui pour nous est serait
une revalorisation de justice je crois
que l'insee a pointé que deux sur ces
dix dernières années les fonctionnaires
ont perdu trois et demi pour cent de
pouvoir d'achat nous le calcul qu'on
avait fait sur un jeune enseignant
débutant sur les 15 dernières années
c'est à peu près 20% de pouvoir d'achat
en moins par rapport à la situation à la
fin des années à la fin du siècle
dernier
cette annonce sur les salaires est
intervenu en clôture des journées sur la
refondation de l'école de la république
on va en parler dans quelques instants
pour voir un petit peu plus comment vous
avez perçu peut-être ce quinquennat
aussi du côté de l'éducation nationale
auparavant je vous propose d'écouter
notre question du jour le gouvernement a
t-il raison justement de se pencher sur
la question des salaires des enseignants
du premier degré bon bah sur le fond oui
parce que bon depuis le temps que les
points à 10 n'ont pas été augmentés et
que de toute façon par rapport aux
autres stylos aux profs il quand même un
écart important donc voila moi je trouve
ça très bien que ça s'aligne sur les
profs puisque c'est là même la meme
longueur d tu donc il y avait aucune
raison qu'ils ne soient pas rénumérés de
la même façon c'est peut-être un peu
tard de se réveiller juste avant
peut-être déjà la période pré électorale
mais je pense que des instituteurs
mérite largement cette prime à moi
personnellement non
je n'approuve pas ils sont largement
payé par rapport à certaines personnes
autre qui en emploient beaucoup plus
difficile évidemment c'est une bonne
idée mais en même temps générant un an
avant les élections ça y est c'est
toujours la même chose quoi une dernière
question justement sur cette thématique
salariale est ce que vous avez le
sentiment d'être achetés aux deux
racheter vous savez il ya beaucoup de
gouvernements qui pense que c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure en faisant une
mesure ici ou là on achète un électorat
je pense que
comme tous les français les enseignants
sont capables de réfléchir par eux-mêmes
et d'engager leurs votes au travers des
éléments politiques qui sont présentés
par chacun des cinq des candidats
j'aurais juste ajouter une chose on
parle beaucoup du budget de l'éducation
nationale
il faut savoir que le budget de
l'enseignement scolaire le budget 2016
puisque en parler de refondation de
l'école est en baisse de 1,4 pour cent
ces terres que l'argent qui est mis
effectivement à disposition de
l'enseignement en france que soit
premier et second degré est en baisse de
1,4 pour cent cette année donc on est
très loin de d'une sanctuarisation
annoncé affiché l'école est dans un état
de extrêmement difficile la réforme du
collège dans le second degré se passe
dans des conditions que l'on va
constater comme étant catastrophique à
la rentrée parce qu'il suffit pas de
renvoyer à l'autonomie de
l'établissement pour constater que tout
va bien mais il faut aussi que les
moyens soient propres à cette autonomie
dans le premier degré le renseignement
le parrain le remplacement a été
catastrophique cette année on évalue à
peu près autour de 20% le nombre de
journées non remplacés dans le premier
degré donc on peut on est très loin d'un
satisfecit en ce qui concerne le
fonctionnement de l'école en général
justement tout au long de ce quinquennat
de françois hollande il ya eu les
rythmes scolaires refonte des programmes
réforme du collège donc d'enseignante et
polémiques depuis 2012 ne sont pas
oubliés vous attendez aussi des des
propositions concrètes on imagine que
les différents syndicats
que ce soit dans l'enseignement mais
aussi dans les autres professions vont
regarder ce que vont proposer les
candidats tout au long de l'année
jusqu'à l'échéance de 2017
bah écoutez vous vous attendez un
changement de cap on achetait un
changement de cap on attend surtout
enfin que le
la france se penche sur la situation de
l'école élémentaire et maternelle et
qu'elle mette enfin les mêmes moyens que
dans les autres pays européens
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu un accent mis sur
des quelques éléments qualitatifs il
faut pas le nier
il ya eu quelques éléments ont parlé de
cette indemnité
mais sur le fond c'est à dire par
exemple les taux d'encadrement sur la
façon dont les choses fonctionnent
il n'y a pas eu d'avancée positive et
par exemple la réforme des rythmes
scolaires qui pouvait être perçu comme
une bonne chose puisque on s'intéressait
enfin au rythme de l'enfant se traduit
par une cacophonie et une
désorganisation assez systématique
je leur ai juste donné un chiffre dans
le département des yvelines une
circonscription qui a 36 horaires
différents dans les écoles comment
peut-on gérer un système éducatif en
ayant laissé comme ça la clé au la clé
du de l'école omer pour votre ministre
aujourd'hui tout va mieux najat vallaud
belkacem dit les choses vont mieux
finalement cette réforme des rythmes
scolaires bah voilà elle est en place et
globalement ça fonctionnait tout le
monde est content tout va mieux mais le
budget de l'enseignement scolaire c'est
moins 1,4 pour cent de moins et nous
n'avons nous n'aurons fait finalement à
la fin de ce quinquennat que rattraper
les dégâts en personnel qui ont été
constatés depuis 2008 sur les rythmes
scolaires kiev quand même fait beaucoup
beaucoup parlé à ces dernières années il
faut en 2017 revenir sur cette réforme
par exemple les rythmes scolaires à
l'écouté je sais pas s'il faut revenir
sur cette réforme parce qu'on a c'est
mais en tout cas nous ce que de moudon
demandons depuis très longtemps c'est
une réécriture du décret de façon à être
au plus près de la réalité du terrain et
de ne pas fonctionner comme souvent pour
nos ministres dans un ailleurs dans un
possible dans un peut-être qui n'est pas
la réalité quotidienne des écoles les
républicains qui eux aussi sont en
campagne et ils ont fait quelques
quelques grandes lignes dégager quelques
grandes lignes autour de l'éducation il
parle d'autorité de mérite de rigueur de
distinction d'excellence sont des mots
qui vont dans le bon sens à écouter
l'autorité venant des républicains c'est
assez amusant dans la mesure où ce sont
les dernier quinquennat qui ont eu lieu
se sont employés à d'une certaine façon
a dénié notre autorité au travers du
fait que les enseignants n'apprenez pas
à lire n'apprenez pas écrire que c'est
une grande partie des ordres de la
société étaient dues à l'école et dans
le même temps on voudrait restaurer
notre autorité soit on considère que les
enseignants sont capables qu'ils ont des
compétences professionnelles et que
leurs autorités se fondent sur ses
compétences professionnelles et à ce
moment là on les soutient dans ses
compétences là soit on estime que ça ne
va pas et on peut pas leur demander en
plus d'avoir une autorité qu on leur
dénie par ailleurs merci bertrand mesure
secrétaire départemental la nuit pp fsu
soixante dix huit syndicats des
professeurs des écoles pour ces quelques
réactions après les annonces du
gouvernement de cette semaine merci et
du sport à présent plus précisément du
tir à l'arc et a aussi marc r 11 ans
licenciée aux archers de guyancourt est
actuellement l'un des plus grands
espoirs de la discipline en france le
sportif classiers septième au niveau
national vient d'être sacré champion
régional d'île de france de la
discipline et ils comptent aller aux
jeux olympiques dans les prochaines
années son portrait signé mickaël
millero tu as aussi murray 11 ans est
l'un des meilleurs archers du
département dans la catégorie benjamins
licencié au club de guyancourt le
sportif a débuté le tir à l'arc à sept
ans après avoir testé le judo le
handball la natation et le tennis
alors pendant les grandes vacances je
m'ennuyais de mon grand-père m'a fait un
un arc donc ben ça m'a plu et après la
rentrée j'ai décidé de m'inscrire
ça m'a plu donc j'ai continué je me
retrouve ici
malgré son jeune âge le palmarès du
prodige déjà bien remplie tao a été
champion départemental de tir en salle
en janvier dernier l'arche a également
terminé quatrième aux championnats de
france le 28 février
une ascension éclair qui déboussolent
son club quand il a commencé le tir à
l'arc c'était quelque chose qui lui
plaisait énormément déjà à l'origine
mais c'est une vraie pile électrique
c'est à dire que il armé est tirée in
arms et il tirait il a réitéré
et voilà il n'était pas dans la
gestuelle il a au fur et à mesure des
années il a développé la gestuelle mais
non je n'aurais jamais pensé que qu'il
en arriverait là jour j'espère beaucoup
pour viser encore plus haut tas au
centre n 7 heures par semaine et
participe à trois compétitions par mois
objectif prendre part aux plus grands
rendez vous sportifs mondiaux aller aux
jeux olympiques parce que c'est ce qu'il
ya de plus ce qui est plus au niveau
sportif
donc c'est intéressant mais avant de
penser aux jeux olympiques sa prochaine
compétition est programmé le week-end du
14 mai à orléans
l'athlète s'alignera sur deux départs le
gruau courteau espère une nouvelle fois
monté sur la plus haute marche du podium
et comme chaque vendredi nous passons
maintenant à l'ex l'essentiel de
l'actualité le zapping des sujets
développés depuis le début de la semaine
dans ce journal
c'est le premier compteur linky
installés dans le département des
yvelines
le 3 mai à maule erdf a lancé le
déploiement de son nouveau compteur
intelligent
l'objectif équipé 90 % du territoire
français en remplaçant 35 millions de
compteurs sur les cinq prochaines années
trois heures devant un écran à répondre
à des tests psychotechniques de français
mathématiques et anglais
ces tests constituent la première étape
de sélection pour antoine ce jeune
yvelinois de 20 ans en formation de
conducteurs travaux cherchent à intégrer
l'armée de terre en tant que
sous-officier dans le génie travaux
l'une des 100 spécialités proposées par
cette armée on m'avait dit c'était assez
facile en fait est là bas ce matin j'ai
pas trouvé que c'était évident le sang
un parti ça je ne sais pas j'ai fait
quasiment tous les métiers qui peuvent
existence sécurité publique
que ce soit en terme de gestion que ce
soit en termes de police judiciaire
puisque j'ai été plus de quatre ans et
demi adjoint dans une sûreté
départementale
j'étais chef d'état majeur j'étais
directeur adjoint tout cela dans le val
de marne en règle
ludovic hoffman succède ainsi à jean
marie salanova qui a quitté ses
fonctions le 8 avril dernier député
maire conseillers départementaux
régionaux ou encore chefs d'entreprise
ils forment le comité de soutien de
françois fillon
ancien premier ministre et candidat à la
primaire de la droite et du centre qui
sait exactement où en est notre pays
notre pays dans l'europe est notre pays
dans le monde et donc par conséquent il
nous paraît celui qui va pouvoir entamer
des réformes très vite parce que c'est
ce dont le pays a besoin
le candidat à la primaire de la droite
et du centre bruno le maire était à
versailles hier soir un déplacement dans
le quartier de satory sur le site et bd
comme où se prépare le véhicule du futur
avant de tenir un nouveau meeting de
campagne
ancien ministre de l'agriculture s'est
exprimé devant près de 500 personnes sur
ses propositions et ses dernières
déclarations notamment concernant le
contrôle des comptes bancaires et
interdit rsa la soirée aura été marquée
également par une altercation avec des
opposants au mariage pour tous comme
vous voyez à l'image d'une le maire a
rappelé qu'il ne reviendrait pas sur la
loi
cette fonction qu'il occupait depuis
huit ans l'élu front national philippe
chevrier conseiller municipal à
rambouillet et conseiller régional d'île
de france a été démis hier de son poste
de secrétaire départemental du parti
c'est en raison de sa participation à la
manifestation à n'diaye à jean marie le
pen à mu et l'histoire de l'esclavagé
dans leur programme scolaire ces élèves
de cm2 de l'école francis poulenc de
guyancourt se plonge ce matin dans
l'histoire française
ça m'a fait du mal pour eux parce qu'ils
avaient rien fait ils étaient des
esclaves nos manuels scolaires
maintenant
abordent lé esclavage de façon explicite
mais le programme d'histoire est très
large
et puis chaque année de plus en plus
large puisqu'on a toute l'histoire du
20e siècle puisque nous sommes au 21ème
siècle
donc en fait on n'a pas toujours
l'occasion de pouvoir approfondir cette
cette histoire et après ce résumé de la
semaine un mot à présent des sujets que
nous développerons à partir de lundi
nous reviendrons est sûre les
commémorations du 8 mai dimanche les
communes vont célébrer la victoire des
alliés sur l'allemagne nazie et la fin
de la seconde guerre mondiale en europe
on notera à magny les hameaux que des
élèves de la commune ont réalisé avec
leur établissement un ouvrage en mémoire
des disparus mardi l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
connaîtra le nom de son nouveau
président jean luc vaissière le
président sortant était en ballottage
défavorable après le vote des
enseignants et des étudiants le conseil
d'administration va maintenant se
prononcer jean-luc baissière qui
pourrait céder à sa place à didier
guillemot que vous voyez à l'image
et puis en début de semaine les
agglomérat les élus de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines vont devoir
désigner une nouvelle fois leurs
présidents et vice présidents
le précédent scrutin avait été annulé
par le tribunal administratif les élus
de la gauche minoritaire demandait a
réintégré lé vice présidence la majorité
de centre-droit d'antan procédé à aucun
changement
deux rendez vous à vous donner avant de
refermer cette édition le premier sur
notre antenne avec et samedi à 19h30 le
nouveau numéro du café politique je
reçois nelly duthu nouvelle maire pcf de
la verrière après la démission d'alain à
jajpur raisons de santé il sera question
de ses priorités pour la ville de ses
engagements écouter justement cet
extrait il est question de sa vision de
la gauche
j'aimerais savoir justement pour vous ce
que ça signifie être communiste
aujourd'hui défendre des valeurs
d'abord
des justice sociale égalité hommes
femmes particulièrement dense et avant
tout des valeurs et quand on a une
mairie en général on essaie de vous
mettre en pratique les valeurs qu'on
défend pour vous parti communiste
aujourd'hui c'est le seul vrai parti de
gauche c'est la gauche il est à gauche
manifestement par contre c'est pas la
seule force de gauche jean l'exclu le
gouvernement socialiste quand même
permettre des mois mais non c'est pas la
seule des forces de gauche y en a
d'autres ne serait ce que dans le front
de gauche qu'on essaie de mettre en
place
et puis d'autres partis politiques qui
sont de gauche et tous deux sont aussi
légitimes que nous apporter leurs
valeurs là autre rendez vous politique
ce week-end ce sera sur l'entraînent
l'antenne de nos confrères de radio
sensations nicolas quillet lovitz eux
recevra dimanche à 18h thibault marshall
co secrétaire départemental du parti de
gauche des yvelines il sera question du
mouvement citoyen nuit debout ou encore
de la mobilisation contre la loi travail
écouter cet extrait le code du travail
n'est pas le principal problème de
l'environnement économique de notre pays
loin de là au contraire et nous sommes
effectivement pour le retrait de cette
loi pour plusieurs raisons bien sûr
parce qu'elle va précariser la
population et parce que enfin d'un point
de vue salariés c'est une atteinte grave
à nos droits mais aussi parce que la
logique même de cette loi est mauvaise
c'est à dire que moi j'entends bien les
concessions faites sur la définition de
licenciement économique ou autre mais
c'est pas bien sûr que ça joue mais ça
ne suffit pas parce que cette loi part
du postulat que la négociation locale et
collective peut déroger à la loi c'est à
dire des plats bon pour vous mais
imaginez que les habitants de telle ou
telle ville décide que le rond point
chez eux ne se prend plus dense dans le
sens habituel mais dans l'autre sens
parce qu'il trouve ça plus esthétique un
regret à bhl avec la loi travail on peut
prendre ce type de décision y compris
complètement al'inverse devant de lot
déroger à la loi
surtout les sur tous les dossiers s'il
ya un accord collectif
c'est ce que prévoit la loi dans un
instant où vos idées sorties et loisirs
avec mélanie poker 7,8 week-end
rendez-vous lundi 18h en direct pour un
nouveau journal replay de nos reportages
et émissions sur le site internet de la
chaîne puis n'oubliez pas que vous
pouvez aussi nous suivre sur les réseaux
sociaux très bon week-end